[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con estos días
de diciembre fue el día internacional de
los derechos humanos y nos acompaña [__]
actas ex embajador de alemania en bogotá
bienvenido a france 24 embajador vamos a
iniciar hablando de colombia que es un
país donde hay graves y sistemáticas
violaciones a los derechos humanos su
embajada junto con la francesa entregan
cada año un premio a destacados
defensores de derechos humanos cuéntenos
quienes lo ganaron este 2020
en este año buenos días sobre todo antes
de nada con francia estamos defendiendo
los derechos humanos en el mundo en
todos los países no solamente en
colombia pero también en otros países en
nuestros también en este año ganó un
proyecto muy lindo muy pequeño se llama
trata de ir y carga en barranquilla ella
se dedicó al trabajo a la ayuda a la
ayuda a inmigrantes y refugiados
venezolanos en este país hacen parte de
una población vulnerable y ella se
comprometió con la integración de
inmigrantes y de refugiados de que
vienen de venezuela muy lindo como dijo
que dije muestra que qué tan grande
puede ser la diferencia que hace una
sola mujer no se ha impresionado mucho
señor estás aquí es que la migración
venezolana es una de las crisis más
graves en el continente desde la
perspectiva de derechos humanos en su
experiencia que tanto hacen o no los
gobiernos latinoamericanos por asegurar
se respetan los derechos de los
migrantes en sus territorios los los
gobiernos de latinoamérica son nuestros
socios en la defensa de derechos humanos
quiero recordar los que que los derechos
humanos la declaración es una lección
aprendida de la segunda guerra mundial
desde las hembras de las naciones unidas
y todos se sumaron a este esfuerzo
porque todos saben que una vida con
derechos humanos es una vida mejor es un
estado de derecho que necesito eso por
eso estamos acompañando a los esfuerzos
de los gobiernos en este país en otros
países de latinoamérica para asegurar el
respeto de derechos humanos embajador y
volvemos a colombia porque después de la
firma del acuerdo de paz entre el
gobierno y las farc los niveles de
violencia se han disminuido
significativamente pese a las
dificultades de la implementación sin
embargo la consolidación de viejos
grupos armados y el surgimiento de
disidencias mantienen a la población
civil
a los líderes sociales en una situación
muy difícil en algunas regiones como de
usted la situación de derechos humanos
en colombia
la situación derechos humanos en
colombia es una situación positiva
tenemos grandes avances en el tema de la
reincorporación de los excombatientes
pero si el fin del conflicto armado no
llevó a un fin de la violencia en el
país
eso tiene que ver también con el respeto
que goza la vida en este país en
regiones muy alejadas que tienen una
presencia del estado muy débil y por eso
si lo que nos preocupa es la situación
de los líderes sociales en las regiones
del país estamos trabajando de la mano
con el gobierno para para luchar contra
este fenómeno pero si no podemos
reemplazar el estado podemos acompañar
lo hacemos con una iniciativa de
visibilidad
para los líderes sociales defendamos la
vida se llama una iniciativa europea muy
linda y los países de la unión europea
presentes en este país se sumaron a eso
y me parece una señal importante al país
que sí importa la vida humana líderes
chinos ya embajador y por último es muy
breve alemania y la unión europea han
jugado un papel muy importante en la
contribución política en materia de
apoyo financiero en la implementación de
los acuerdos de paz en colombia' qué
balance hace usted a cuatro años de esta
firma
la balanza es muy positivo en el tema de
la incorporación de los excombatientes
estamos avanzando en este tema pero si
lo que nos falta es un desarrollo rural
y por eso estamos invirtiendo mucho
dinero con otros países para asegurar
que se haya un desarrollo económico en
el país señor embajador pues muchísimas
gracias y a ustedes gracias por
continuar con nosotros sigan aquí con
más en france 24
[Música]